N
TONIGHT."
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE DOWNSIDE OF
CARTELS AS THEY PRODUCE LOUSY
PRODUCTS SERVING UP THE SAME
GARBAGE HAS TO HAVE NO CHOICE,
THE UPSIDE IS ULTIMATELY THEY
ARE OVERTHROWN, SOME UPSTART
SHOWS UP WITH A BETTER PRODUCT
AND CRUSHES THEM.
WE JUST SAW THAT HAPPEN IN
LATE-NIGHT COMEDY, AND HAS BEEN
SERVING UP INCREASINGLY MEDIOCRE
AFFAIR.
UNTIL GREG GUTFELD SHOWED UP AND
COMPLETELY OVERTURN THE TABLE.
THE NUMBERS ARE IN, FOR THE
MONTH OF AUGUST I GOT FELLED THE
SHOW RANKED AS THE MOST-WATCHED
LATE-NIGHT PROGRAM ON ALL
TELEVISION.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT A
CABLE SHOW HAS BEATEN THE
BROADCAST SHOWS.
UNSEATED THE THOROUGHLY
REPULSIVE AND COMPLETELY UNFUNNY
STEPHEN COLBERT.
WE WON'T LET THIS MOMENT PASS
WITHOUT CELEBRATING, WE ARE
GOING TO CELEBRATE AS YOU
SHOULD.
GREG GUTFELD IS THE MAN WHO JUST
DID THIS AND PULLED IT OFF.
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO WELCOME HIM
AND CONGRATULATE HIM.
SO I DID NOT MEAN THAT IT IS
EASY TO DO THIS, IT'S HARD TO DO
THIS, BUT THREE YEARS AGO IF HE
SAID GREG GUTFELD IS GOING TO
BEAT ALL THREE LATE-NIGHT
BROADCAST SHOWS, POSSIBILITY WAS
ZERO, SO HOW DID YOU DO THIS?
>> I DID IT BECAUSE OF YOU,
TUCKER, I BELIEVE THAT YOU DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND THE CONVERSATION
WE HAD.
REMEMBER WHEN I CALLED YOU?
I SAID THAT I JUST TALKED TO A
WELL-KNOWN TALK SHOW HOST, WON'T
SAY THE NAME WHO DISCOURAGE ME
FROM DOING THIS, AND YOU HAVE A
GOOD THING GOING, YOU HAVE ONE
NIGHT A WEEK ON SATURDAY COMING
IN ON WHAT, YOU DON'T WANT TO
KICK IT TOO HARD.
AND I GO OKAY.
BUT I SAID IT WAS NOT GOING TO
DO IT, AND THEN I SAID I WILL
CALL YOU AND BEFORE I EVEN
FINISH THE SENTENCE, I SAID I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE SHOW GOING
NIGHTLY, YOU JUST STARTED
LAUGHING.
YOU DID YOUR TUCKER LAUGH AND
NEW SAID OF COURSE YOU ARE GOING
TO DO IT.
OF COURSE YOU ARE GOING TO DO
IT.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT, AND HE SAID
WHY WON'T YOU DO IT.
AND KEPT GIVING EXCUSES, NO, NO,
YOU ARE DOING THAT.
SO LIKE A TOTALLY --
WHY AM I NOT DOING THIS?
AND IT'S BEEN SUCH A SUCCESS I
WAS IN L.A. FOR EIGHT DAYS LAST
WEEK.
YOU DON'T HEAR ANYTHING.
YOU JUST GET THE STAIRS.
AND I FEEL LIKE I HAVE BROKEN A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN PERSONALLY
HUMILIATED BY THE FACT THAT A
FOX NEWS PROGRAM HAS DRANK ALL
OF THEIR MILK SHAKES AT ONCE.
ALL OF THE NETWORKS, WE HAVE
CRUSH THEM.
THEN AND PROFESSIONALLY THEY
HAVE TO WORRY BECAUSE ALL OF
THEIR BOSSES SEE THAT THIS
LITTLE UPSTART SHOW AT THE
FRACTION OF THE COST, FRACTION
OF THE STAFF BEAT THEIR
UNDERPANTS OFF AND NOW THEY HAVE
TO LOOK AT THEIR BUDGETS AND GO,
DO WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF CATERING?
IT'S LIKE MY WRITERS EAT THEIR
SANDWICH, THEY DON'T HAVE
CATERING, BUT EVERYWHERE ELSE
HAS CATERING, THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
CATERING, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE LESSON IS YOU
DESERVE CRAFT SERVICES AND HAVE
EARNED IT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE TO FIND
SOMETHING USEFUL WITH THEIR
LIVES AND I CANNOT BE MORE
THRILLED, BECAUSE A GOOD GUY
WON, BAD PEOPLE LOST IN THE
MARKET DECIDED.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TO CELEBRATE, BUT I HOPE IT IS
BIG.
>> I DO, BASICALLY I VOLUNTEER
AT SOUP KITCHENS, THAT'S WHAT I
DO TO MAKE MYSELF FEEL BETTER.
I HAVE TO PAY YOU, PART OF THE
REASON IT IS SUCCESSFUL IS THAT
WE ARE GENERALLY HAPPY PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THAT TV.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
COMPLETELY RIGHT AND IMPORTANT